[Music]  welcome back season two of the drew  barrymore show kicks off monday  september 13th one week from today and  man is it going to be huge so huge in  fact  it's by coastal  we're doing shows in new york and we're  doing shows in los angeles that's right  i'm going back to my hometown to  celebrate the people and places  where i grew up it's very personal  actually and very invitational  over the course of the premiere we're  gonna celebrate your hometowns as well  because as they say  there's no place like home  and it's all happening one week from  today the season two premiere of the  emmy nominated drewberry moore show my  goodness  make sure to come join us tune in thanks  for watching see you soon  hopefully  [Music]